one of the peak reality show moments of
last night's State of the Union address
by Donald Trump running 78 minutes and
being riddled with lies and distortion
and reality show moments one of the
things that was absent was policy and
Donald Trump instead did cheap stunts
like surprising extremist right-wing
radio host Rush Limbaugh with the
Presidential Medal of Freedom
check out that moment rush in the news
lately because he announced that he has
been diagnosed with advanced lung cancer
he was there as Trump's guest and here
is Trump surprising him with the
Presidential Medal of Freedom I am proud
to announce tonight that you will be
receiving our country's highest civilian
honor the Presidential Medal of Freedom
shortly after this Melania Trump put the
metal on rush so I want to be really
clear here I'm not happy rush limbaugh
has lung cancer we're gonna hear a
voicemail later today from a caller
about this I find Rush Limbaugh's
politics disgusting and destructive but
I would not wish cancer on anyone I know
personally the nightmare of having a
loved one diagnosed with cancer and
serious illness I have nothing to say
that would even hint at pleasure at Rush
Limbaugh having cancer separate from
that Rush Limbaugh is a disgusting
horrible extremist who should not have
the Medal of Freedom it devalues the
honor of the Medal of Freedom to give it
to Rush Limbaugh this is the Rush
Limbaugh who called Barack Obama the
magic Negro in a song parody this is
Paul Franklin as al Sharpton about
Barack Obama
[Music]
this is a guy who mocked Michael J Fox
as Parkinson's by pretending to shake
uncontrollably and claim that Michael J
Fox is playing up the Parkinson's in
this commercial he is exaggerating the
effects of the disease he is moving all
around and shaking and it's purely an
act this is the only time I have ever
seen Michael J Fox portray any of the
symptoms of the disease he had he can't
control himself enough to stay in the
frame of the picture
and he can control himself enough to
keep his eyes right on the lens the
teleprompter that guy is the one that
Donald Trump surprised with the
Presidential Medal of Freedom last night
you know my girlfriend's grandmother was
awarded the Presidential Medal of
Freedom by President Clinton for a
life's work cleaning up children's
television developing educational
programming keeping advertisers that are
predatory to kids out of kids TV working
with the House and Senate improving
people's lives and then Rush Limbaugh
gets it after Barack the magic negro and
making fun of Parkinson's it's a guy
rush limbaugh with a career of sexist
racist xenophobic comments famously
calling healthcare advocate Sandra Fluke
a [ __ ] that was an entire other national
fiasco so the medal ends up meaning less
instantly when Donald Trump gives it to
Rush Limbaugh in this cartoonish reality
show stunts meant merely to get
attention it's classless to use a
national address to give a reactionary
talk-show host a medal for nothing more
than being a trunk trump supporter
because that's really what this is about
Limbaugh is sick now he supports Trump
and here's a way to do something that
will get attention imagine for a second
like it's hard to even come up with an
example like Bill Maher or Jon Stewart I
don't even know imagine that Barack
Obama was impeached by a Republican
House and hours from being acquitted by
a Democratic Senate in a total sham
trial and the day before during a State
of the Union Barack Obama says surprise
Bill Maher or
surprise Jon Stewart here's the
Presidential Medal of Freedom the right
would go nuts they would be apoplectic
and you know Bill Maher and Jon Stewart
aren't even good examples because they
were critical of Barack Obama there
almost is not a good example we are
living in a society where logic reason
and thought have been replaced by
ignorant pandering and almost a proud
proud defiance about falling for one
thing to fall for wanting to be sucked
into these meaningless stunts the
reality show nature of what's going on
and we're in trouble I mean we're just
in serious trouble
as a result let me know what you thought
about the State of the Union address I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman follow me there
follow the show on twitter at david
pakman show as well